this is it ladies and gentlemen castle
rock has only two episodes and if this
promo is any indication they're gonna be
action-packed so if you haven't seen the
promo yet I put the link in the
description below check it out and make
sure to come back here we go the video
begins with Henry reciting his full name
and what seems to be some sort of
interrogation after his discovery notice
how Henry is wearing the same jacket
from episode 1 and these son defusing
glasses not unlike what Molly wears when
her powers become too unstable remember
at this point he suffers from amnesia so
this question period probably won't go
over that well it's entirely possible
that this scene takes place wherever
Henry actually went to when he
disappeared so keep that in mind whether
that be an alternate universe or some
other place we hear his father say do
you hear it now with some quick flashes
notably what seems to be Henry's feet
next to the soap carving he held an
episode one the kids voice over says we
have to go as we see young Henry bundled
up with police lights in their
background which is a bit odd since it
was Pangborn who saved Henry and brought
him directly to his mother making this
alternate timeline theory a bit more
realistic we then get more quick flashes
a swarm of birds crows or Ravens just
like the one that flew into the bus in
episode 8 this is likely some sort of
dream judging by the ridiculously large
Sun or perhaps that's the heavens
opening up a tape recorder plays one of
Mathew Devers sermons likely the same
tapes the kid found in episode 6 he says
as long as the devil walks the streets
of Castle Rock tragedy after tragedy
will pile up until he is back in that
cage but who is he referring to is it
the kid or Henry we see a knife taken
out from the Deaver kitchen I think this
is Matthew not the kid as you can make
out a watch here which the kid has never
worn outside the Church of the
Incarnation you can make out a man
holding a cane it's hard to make out the
face but it looks like it could be the
kid a car swerved off the road carrying
what appears to be Molly and the kid we
did see her swerving on the road in
episode 8 could this be a crash a school
bus gets decimated by a train an
emergency vehicle rushes across a bridge
and the kid runs away from what appears
to be the police before we get the most
important shot of the prone
the kid in what might be present day
looking at the cage he saved Henry from
finally the video ends with the kid
asking Molly do you believe me now with
this episode being titled Henry Deaver I
think we're about to get an avalanche of
new revelations Wednesday can't come
fast enough as always if you liked this
video make sure to LIKE and subscribe
and stay tuned for my full episode
breakdown every Thursday Cheers